en principio y lo han mencionado incluso
desde después del triunfo electoral es
que los más ricos van a pagar más es
decir va a ser una reforma tributaria
que va a gravar con más impuestos a ese
segmento que como bien lo decía ha
gustado petro en su discurso pues
concentrado tiene el mayor punto de
riqueza digamos en la piel en nuestro
país entonces eso es lo primero que se
espera obviamente se van a esperar
algunas exenciones porque las reformas
tributarias siempre han tener secciones
sobre todo no porque el gobierno lo
busquen sino porque efectivamente se
tiene que dialogar y se tiene que
negociar en el congreso y obviamente los
representantes los senadores pues tienen
unos intereses regionales y no intereses
de su electorado porque no graven
digamos a sus a sus ciudadanos es
obviamente el alcance de la reforma
tributaria va a ser muy importante la
coalición que tiene pero también cómo va
a jugar la oposición un poco frente a
hacer recortes en ese presupuesto de ser
muy importante que desde el 8 de agosto
desde mañana mismo pues obviamente como
se van a mujeres a fuerzas políticas ya
sea para reducir o para ampliar un poco
más el alcance de esa reforma tributaria
que obviamente va a ser esa para
permitir aumentar un poco el programa
social del gobierno o petro